hey youtubers it's Charlie so yesterday
during my error of you I asked you to
submit all your questions about the
episode so I picked 10 of them to answer
in this video with one bonus question so
we also got some big news about one of
our Merlin's coming back so I'll talk
about that too if you're finding me for
the first time I do Q&A videos like this
for all the Big Show's that I do be sure
to subscribe to get everything I'm also
working on a special arrow cat down
series it's gonna start next Wednesday
too so before we do questions let's talk
about Merlin because we just found out
that he's coming back in episode 22
that's right they just posted the
description for Streets of Fire and it
talks about Thea running into Merlin or
Merlin running into Thea it's hard to
tell what's gonna happen but based on
what happens in that episode we can kind
of guess what he's gonna be doing in the
finale you know whether or not he's
gonna be fighting with team arrow
against Slade or doing something
completely different but we'll have to
wait to find out
so onto questions careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet but
here we go question number one comes
from Drew Cole who asks do you think
that Laurel will tell Oliver she knows
he's the arrow or will she just keep it
to herself
so I think she'll listen to what Quentin
said and just keep it to herself when
she went to hug him you could tell that
she wanted to support him and if she had
told him he'd probably be way too
distracted worrying about her to fight
Slade you know add to that all the extra
problems with Queen industries Thea and
Roy right now and you arrive at hug time
so really the best thing that she could
have done for him in that moment was
give him a hug and she did which is why
it was so awesome
I think her relationship with team arrow
will be just like Quentin's in season 3
except she'll know who they are but they
won't know that she knows she'll be like
a stealth member of team arrow so
stealth that Oliver won't even know that
she's on the team question number 2
babymaker asks wow what a name why does
Oliver keep calling Thea speedy so
speedy is just his affectionate nickname
for her as her older brother he uses it
whenever he wants to show he cares about
her it's one of the ways he shows his
brotherly affection it's not meant to
foreshadow that she's gonna becomes a
speedy character from the comic books
I've seen a lot of you commenting to on
whether or not you think she's gonna
become the Artemis character but I think
we're gonna have to wait to see what
happens in the finale to know where her
character's going she's kind of blowing
around in the wind right now I think
what's gonna end up happening with her
character in in relation to Merlyn
specifically is that it's gonna be like
when Oliver's father had to choose
between Isabel rochev and his family
Thea will just be forced to choose
between Merlyn and her family I don't
think he's gonna train her or anything
like that and if she ever did become a
member of team arrow it would be way
more fun to watch Oliver train her just
imagine her slapping endless bowls of
water like Roy question number three
Sharmila nests what about the bandage on
Roy's arm could that have been part of
the plot to clone him like they did with
Cadmus labs so you're thinking like
Superman's Superboy situation you know I
don't think that's gonna happen it would
be really interesting but I think they'd
only choose to clone a metahuman like
someone with actual superpowers and Roy
is just juiced up on mirakuru the
bandages are probably just wherever they
attach the machine to his veins to get
blood out I think if they ever ended up
doing a cloning storyline in the future
especially with STAR Labs involved
they'd use it as a flash crossover
opportunity so it would have to be some
big epic thing that just seems like it'd
be way too complicated for them to do on
the flash show in the first season you
know they're trying to keep that as
simple as possible there's already a ton
of new characters they have to introduce
but they could always do that in the
future question number four legitimate
gamer your totally legit how did Slade
get inside the arrow cave if he didn't
have one of those super Keys like the
one Felicity stole off the clock King so
you have to remember that he's
ex-special forces so he has a lot of
experience and now he's juiced up on
mirakuru and he's almost indestructible
as Special Forces he had a lot of
experience breaking into places mostly
to kill people I imagine like he almost
did team arrow the real reason he broke
in there was to just spank them for
setting his operation back blowing up
that plant that's why he had to raid
STAR Labs to get the new device I
totally loved that Felicity's stole that
key off the clocking though it just
shows that she takes advantage of
opportunities when she sees them like
you know window shopping for cool new
toys to use in the arrow cave question
number five Green quiver asks how do you
think danielle Panabaker will become
killer frost so this is where things get
really interesting because based on her
relationship with Felicity and Cisco in
the episode it seems like she's one of
the good guys but since she's such a big
character from the comics I think yes
eventually she'll become a version of
killer frost but I think on the show
she's just gonna start out being a good
person
the real question though is what is her
character art gonna be on the flash at
least in season one
like if she gonna start out as a good
person researcher then she gets in a
horrible accident it turns evil or if
she's just gonna be a normal person that
gets corrupted by zoom or someone else
then there's also the possibility that
she could become killer frost but just
like arrow kind of truncated a lot of
the super names they could just call her
Frost so that could leave the window
open for her to be a good superhero just
like when they turned Oliver into the
arrow instead of turning him into the
Green Arrow when you decide to use a
name like killer frost you kind of
telegraphed what a character story arc
is gonna be and I think they want that
to be more of a mystery for us as the
fans they want to leave open the
possibility that she could be a good
character no matter what happens though
I think she's gonna be a normal person
for the duration of season 1 or at least
most of season 1 I think the flash and
zoom are gonna be the only real you know
super superpower people I think any of
the Rogues that end up popping up or
villains will just be using tech you
know like the arts are like gun that
they have locked up in storage as
opposed to you know new people being
full on metahumans but the really cool
thing is though is that they said there
would be more superpowers on the show
eventually just not right away question
number 6 f sniper asks do you think team
arrow will use the cure for Slade and
then use it on Roy I think we actually
need to ask whether or not it's gonna be
a situation where they have to pick one
or the other like they'll be able to
cure Roy but not Slade logically you
think they'd be able to synthesize a ton
of it and now that we know there is a
cure I think that's how Oliver's gonna
get rid of all the new super soldiers so
let's just say that they'll be able to
make a bunch of it you know enough to do
Roy and Slade I definitely think that
they're gonna cure Roy because he's not
leaving the show Colton Haynes isn't
leaving the show and Roy's got to finish
his Jedi training so that he can become
Arsenal asks for Slade though I think
everyone even the writers want him to be
able to continue on as the Deathstroke
character but you know maybe a slightly
less insane version so I think they'll
end up using the Cure on him too but
they won't kill him and he'll just
disappear the same way Merlyn did after
season 1 they'll just leave it open for
him to return in the future at some
point and I think he's gonna appear a
whole lot at season 3 though I think
they're gonna open the window for new
villains to come in question number 7
Daniel ma des Lee asks do you think that
Laura will confront Sara about being the
canary before the end of the season I
actually think we're gonna get a
spider-man 2 situation you know that
Tobey Maguire's spider-man where they
find out at the end remember when he was
saving Mary Jane from Doctor Octopus and
his mask came off and she saw it was him
and they had that special moment I think
they'll do a reverse version of that you
know because it'll be more from Sarah's
perspective since Laurel has already
kind of figured out who she is they'll
have like a sister moment whenever Sarah
gets unmasked in battle I think it'll
probably end up happening in the season
finale but I think until they have that
mutual sister moment she's gonna treat
Sarah just like she treats Oliver right
now you know just give her hugs all the
time
question number eight harsh asks do you
think that Oliver will become the mayor
of the city like in the comics only if
Moore ends up dying this season there's
still a funeral scene in episode 21 and
we don't know who it's for it could be
Slade just doing a fake funeral for
Isabel rochev so that he can surprise
them with Ravager later otherwise I
think they're just gonna let Moira have
that mayor story arc yes I do think it
would be more interesting to let Oliver
do that but we'll just have to wait and
see what happens
question number nine Elizabeth asks the
producers have hinted that Felicity's
backstory is gonna be a big thing in
season three but can we possibly get a
cliffhanger about it in the finale
definitely the major arc for the next
season always gets teed up by whatever
ends up happening in the finale or at
least teased
so whatever the resolution of the Slade
storyline is it'll be related to
Felicity's backstory maybe just in a
minor way but keep your eyes peeled for
special felicity stuff in episode 23
quick side note though I am totally
hoping that Felicity's father ends up
turning out to be the villain of season
three and someone connected to hive
question number 10 Shmuel a asks with
the Booster Gold TV series supposedly in
the works do you think we'll see a cameo
in the flash or an arrow so Booster Gold
has always spent more time in the flash
universe so I think if he does show up
somewhere it'll be there they could also
end up using it as an arrow crossover
just to guarantee the show a bigger
audience but I don't think we'll see him
until season two I don't think they're
gonna try and complicate that flash
storyline in season 1 by throwing in a
ton of extra characters but Geoff Johns
has totally been working on getting a
Booster Gold show going for a long time
so if he has anything to say about it
you will see Booster Gold sooner rather
than later and one last bonus question
Vaughn O'Hara asks do you think we'll
see any more flash characters this
so I think the only flash crossover
we'll see for the rest of the season is
one for the mirakuru cure storyline and
two for Felicity visiting Barry in
Central City I don't think that they're
gonna show Felicity going to Central
City
I think they'll just have a scene where
she says she's going to visit him in the
finale you know after everything's over
so thank you so much for so many
questions guys it's always a lot of fun
to be able to answer you directly in a
video like I said I'm doing bonus videos
every Wednesday morning now counting
down to the finale feel free to suggest
topics for those in the comments below
and subscribe to get them if you're
finding me for the first time in the
meantime click here to get my review the
episode and click here to get my finale
predictions thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives